Donald Trump on Saturday called for both
himself and Hillary Clinton who take a
drug test prior to the third
presidential debate which is wednesday
during a campaign rally Saturday in New
Hampshire the Republican presidential
nominee compared himself in Hillary
Clinton to athletes may be a bit of a
stretch of a comparison but let's take a
look at the video where he called for
this drug test like athletes right so
athletes that making them more and more
but a fleets they make them take a drug
test right I think we should take a drug
test prior to the debate I did I think
we should why don't we do that we should
take a drug test prior cuz I don't know
what's going on with her but at the
beginning of her last debate she was all
pumped up at the beginning and at the
end it was like huh take me down she
could barely reach your car so I think
we should take a drug test I'm anyway
I'm willing to do it really hitting all
the major campaign issues at this rally
huh I do sort of feel bad for the
writers of house of cards right now they
have to get together and create
something crazier and more outrageous
than the real world campaign were
experiencing I imagine the writers of
house of cards sitting in a room writing
for the upcoming season and then that
night they see the latest in same thing
Trump says like we should be all taking
drug we should all be taking drug tests
before the debates and then they get
back together the next day and they
scrap all of those ideas and they say
it's just not crazy enough it's too
believable it doesn't even seem nuts
because of what Donald Trump has been
doing and Scott Adams who's the creator
of Gilbert I grew up loving Dilbert and
I've been really distraught at some of
the insane pro Trump stuff that Scott
Adams has been saying lately he wrote an
article where he said he believed
Hillary Clinton engineered 90 minutes of
alertness at the first debate with some
kind of performance-enhancing drugs I'm
not against a pre-debate drug test in
principle if the candidates also
subjected themselves to a pre debate
psych evaluation and then I think we'd
be all on the same page and of course
she's not on any performance-enhancing
drugs she just studies and knows our
stuff is prepared for what
happen on stage and of course he's not
willing to do the same thing Trump
reacting to the fact that Hillary seemed
so ready for those questions they just
they mentioned stuff to her and she knew
what it was and you all about it it's
just crazy uh the other angle of course
knowing that there won't be a pre-debate
drug test is that Trump is doing this to
push back against the cocaine rumors
based on the constant sniffing at
debates I'm gonna play a clip for you
okay you tell me whether you can
understand what Trump says here without
accounting for some kind of substance
that the guy is on having nuclear my
uncle was a great professor and
scientist and engineer dr. John Trump at
MIT good good genes very good genes okay
very smart the Wharton School of Finance
very good very smart you know if you're
a conservative Republican if I were a
liberal if like okay if I ran as a
liberal Democrat they would say I'm one
of the smartest people that were in the
world right screw but when you're a
conservative Republican they try or do
they do a number that's why I always
sort of went to Wharton was a good
student went there went there did this
built before yet I have to give my like
credentials all the time because we're a
little disadvantage but you look at the
nuclear deal the thing that really
bothers me it would have been so easy
and it's not as important as these lives
are nuclear is so powerful my uncle
explained that to me many many years ago
the power and that was 35 years ago he
would explain the power of what's going
to happen and he was right who would
have thought but when you look at what's
going on with the four prisoners now
used to be three now it's four but when
it was three and even now go on I would
have said it's on the messenger fellas
and its fellows because you know they
don't they haven't figured that the
women are smarter right now than the men
suck you know going to take them about
another 150 years but the Persians a
great negotiate is the Iranians are
great English so and they they just
killed they just yes that was one
sentence I mean that that was one minute
and a half run on tendons if I were
Trump I would want to attribute that to
drug use because if that's just the way
you think and speak you obviously can't
handle being president of the United
States which is something that we
already know so very very strange and if
if the you know a technique that some
are suggesting is Trump knows there
won't be a drug test Trump is suspected
of having been on drugs because of all
that sniffing so what you do is you go
out there you say we should drug test
because I think Hillary's on drugs
people will say from would never call
for a drug test if he was on something
right brilliant technique from Trump of
misdirection here and Lance Armstrong
did the same thing when that guy
stations were coming out in the early
two thousands against them yep no doubt
about it so when you see more similarity
between Trump and Lance Armstrong than
Trump and any other president we've ever
had it should make you question what the
hell was going on here is Donald Trump
likes to say